president biden and other leaders are
welcoming sweden and finland to the
western military alliance nancy cordes
is in madrid traveling with the
president with a look at the
significance of that breakthrough nancy
good morning
good morning vlad you know it isn't just
that sweden and finland are two large
resource-rich nations now joining nato
it's the message that it sends to
russian president vladimir putin that
his efforts to destabilize nato
backfired
nato's 30 member countries are poised to
add two more the move will more than
double the length of nato's border with
russia and i'm pleased to announce that
we now have an agreement sweden and
finland applied for nato membership last
month
putin's decision to invade one neighbor
had them worried he might be willing to
attack another after 200 years of
military non-alignment
sweden has chosen a new path president
biden helped to broker the deal russia's
attempts to rattle the west have instead
led to a larger western alliance that is
better funded and surging troops to the
russian border food was looking for the
femalization of europe
you're going to get the natoization of
europe roughly 8 million ukrainians have
now been displaced by the bombing first
lady dr jill biden visited a refugee
center outside madrid yesterday
fulfilling a promise she says she made
to ukraine's first lady when they met
last month i told her you know that i
would carry forth her message that we
supported her in an interview with cbs
news the first lady weighed in for the
first time on last week's supreme court
decision to overturn roe v wade
what's your message to american women
and particularly young women who are
waking up to a very different reality
when it comes to
access to abortion uh it's you know this
decision was so
unjust and so devastating
but my message is
let's not give up let's keep working
just this morning president biden
announced more deployments to seven
european nations including two navy
destroyer ships that'll be coming here
to spain it's all meant to increase the
pressure on vladimir putin as his
invasion of ukraine drags on nate
nancy cordes in madrid thank you